sometimes it's impossible to separate
the company from the founder Mark
Zuckerberg and Facebook Steve Jobs and
Apple Elon Musk and Tesla for better or
worse it's hard to see anyone thinking
about you were without quickly thinking
about you know Travis kalanick but
that's not always a good thing for the
company
that's our newcomer and cover number and
startups for Bluebird Callen ik has
become a lightning rod of controversy in
the tech industry over the past few
years Seth Meyers said he's what happens
when you wear a Axe body spray into his
suit until it became sentient and right
now Callen a canoe bur his 69
billion-dollar brainchild are at an
inflection point this is the story of
how Travis kalanick built one of the
most successful and controversial tech
companies in the world Travis kalanick
was born in 1976 in Los Angeles he
attended UCLA to study engineering and
he also started his first company an
online file exchange service called
scour with some of his UCLA classmates
months before graduating he dropped out
to work on scour the whole time I was
back in sort of the Napster days and it
was a sort of a failed effort Scour
ended up getting sued by almost every
major entertainment label to the tune of
250 billion dollars and the company went
into chapter 11 undaunted he started
another company called Reds Rouge which
was another peer-to-peer file-sharing
service the company Acme bought it for
19 million which was obviously a nice
success for Travis but I think from his
perspective he didn't build the empire
that he'd hoped to flush with cash after
selling red swooosh Callen ik was
looking to make his next move the story
goes he was in Paris with his friend
Garrett camp who had founded social
sites StumbleUpon and they started
talking about this idea of calling a car
with a push of a button
he started uber originally called uber
cab in 2009 and was first thought of as
a luxury service it was a black car
business
it wasn't this sort of peer-to-peer
ride-sharing it was you know nice black
cars and this was meant to get a car
whenever they wanted to get a nice car
but when its main competitor entered the
marketplace in 2012
uber had to pivot once it was obvious
that lyft was going to be successful and
be able to do this peer-to-peer
ride-sharing business
he was savvy enough to launch his own
products so Callen ik well known as an
extremely strong salesperson raised a
huge amount of money they raised you
know hundreds of millions from around
from Google Ventures and TPG and created
uber X which is really the defining
product which lets people sign up with
basically the car they have without
having to have been this legacy black
car worker almost single-handedly
calendar created what we now call the
gig economy paying independent
contractors through an app for a service
whether it's cleaning a home delivering
food or being a chauffeur even though
the company is twelve thousand people
now you very much has a reputation for
trying to sort of cut through
bureaucracy and keep it like a start-up
mcallen dick has also been criticized
for a number of incidents the Buber
incident comes up sort of so often in a
2014 GQ profile of Callen ik he referred
to his company as Boober because of his
increased success with women as the CEO
of uber then the PR missteps kept coming
in just the first three months of 2017
alone there were enough gaffes leaked
videos and negative headlines that can
easily sink a company they blame every
there's this constant clamor for him to
grow up the company is sort of in the
middle of trying to decide whether he
can really be their identity both
publicly and internally so whether
Callen exchanges ubers culture or hires
a CEO o to do it for him he's not going
anywhere
he'll either steer uber ship back on
course or go down with it
[Music]